hi everybody and so yes so my name is
Kevin Wilson I'm a principal data
scientist at Newton and we're sort of we
ran EdTech company down in the Union
Square area and I thought today I'd talk
a bit about some of the problems that we
face at Newton as an EDD tech company
sort of talk about what we do what
problems we face and then in sort of the
latter half talk about basically some
some basic techniques for solving them
so hopefully I'm not sure how familiar
you you are with like all of the sort of
like your usual modeling toolkit things
like maximum likelihood estimation and
things like this so hopefully I'm going
to hit the right range of talks and if
you if anybody says this seems very
boring then feel free to be like I know
these things but just to sort of give
you an overview of what Newton does so
what we do is that basically there's a
lot of online content available there
are a huge host of this that's been put
together by publishers over the years
the sort of print to digital education
thing has been happening for a while but
a lot of a lot of times what isn't sort
of taken care of in this sort of print
to digital move is actually harnessing
the power of like computers and
recommendation systems and machine
learning we know about sort of put data
together about what students are doing
and the content that they have so what
we sort of what we what Newton does we
work with content providers to basically
provide that piece and our platform so
we provide recommendations for students
as they're going through courses so you
know they're working on things you're
doing really well that probably musician
before oh they're doing really poorly
why are they doing poorly which which of
the things is it oh you it's like you
should probably working on this so
recommendations in that vein learning
analytics for students and teachers so
you know what sort of data can we
surface and aggregates thereof to
students and teachers about what they're
what they're doing and what their
students are doing to sort of make
learning more effective for them and
also content insights for publishers so
what content is most effective are there
pieces of content that some people
really like or the pieces of content
that always cause people to do worse I
mean these are you know that's not an
unheard-of thing that happens in content
and so this is basically sort of what
Newton does and and other things but
these are the main things and so just
sort of sum over you like what data
problems
face so we have sort of like these are
some example questions that we have to
ask all the time so big one is what do
students know that's sort of the very
first thing that we have to ask about
any sort of thing we do what do students
know and a very sec and the second thing
we have to ask is when do they learn it
because we're working with students
learning things and so there's this
whole process of they start off knowing
nothing perhaps and they're supposed to
go to learning something to knowing
something so anything that they know it
day one isn't the same thing as what
they know at day 7 isn't the same thing
to know at the end of the semester so
there's sort of this temporal process
that we have to deal with other
questions that we ask for things like
our students engage that's very
important you know if they're very bored
they're not going to learn anything etc
how effective our particular piece of
content that goes back to the
Continental Enix and a big one so if you
ever talk to a data scientist and they
don't mention that they actually asked
the question how do they measure success
then you should just stop listening to
them so i have to mention that we have
to ask this question quite a lot of how
do we actually measure our own success
and so these are sort of some of the
data problems that we face and today i
kind of want to talk about you know this
is about talk about determining skill
levels and so what do so these sort of
problems fall into the what do students
know and when did they know it and in
fact the when do they know it's beyond
this talk I only have half an hour and I
can talk forever about temporal models
of student proficiency and things like
this and so we're going to talk about
the what do students no part of this and
specifically there's sort of like this
there are these big sort of sort of four
sub questions of that so how do you
assess students about and what subject
you're assessing them on what time are
you assessing them and what setting are
you assessing them in and so the first
question of how to assess so there's
this big problem where a lot of things
like you know if you want to do
something like if you're an
electrophysiologist and you know you
want to say like measure what's
happening a monkey's brain you shove
electrodes in there and you figure out
what's in a monkey's brain unfortunately
monkeys are not humans or sorry humans
aren't monkeys from this perspective and
so we can't shove electrodes in the
brain we can't to see directly into
their minds we have to we could only
indirectly asked them questions about
what they know so actually setting up
those questions of what we're assessing
and how are assessing is like a
really really important question
alignment and coding or sort of the big
buzz words in in that field of
psychometrics so this is one of the big
questions you have to ask what subject
are reassessing is another big one so
this is part of the Common Core standard
through sixth grade statistics and
probability that's the P at the bottom
and you can see there's sort of this
whole hierarchy of subjects you know
summarizing and describing distributions
well you can display numerical data and
floss on a number line that's one big
bullet points up there another one
summarized numerical data sets in their
context and that has even more sub
bullet points so you can imagine asking
this question of what subject are we
even assessing them on and you could
imagine so like take the s80 they
wouldn't even be at this level they
would be at something much higher called
math right when they are going to assess
their topic is going to be math but from
what we want to do we want to sort of
know about what people are at these sort
of very fine levels and there's a whole
spectrum in between and sort of making
sure you know at what level you're at is
another big problem that we hit at a
particular time so this is a good like
1919 very sorry 1898 seen when people
when you ask people questions both in
terms of where they are developmentally
as well as where they are in a course
are all very important the particular
time relative to their life and relative
to the world is actually can be very
very important you can't reference
things like the Eiffel Tower before the
Eiffel Tower existed and so like all
these sorts of things really influence
how you build questions and how you
actually see their effect on students
and finally in a particular setting we
all sort of know that you know high
stress test environments tend to like
cause people problems and whatnot so
that's you know that they do worse in
high stress test environments but they
also do worse if they're on the beach
right they're not gonna be paying
attention on the beach so where they're
doing these things can actually be can
also influence what data you see in what
not these are all sorts of things that
we have to think about whenever you're
sort of doing these assessment type
things and so today we're just going to
take them all is fixed because once
again temporal models and late and other
sort of multi factor models are beyond
the scope of this talk if you are
curious about these things then feel
free to send me an email and i will talk
your ear off for hours and hours and
hours
but for this talk just know that these
things exist and there we're going to be
building into all of our models these
assumptions that we recessed we've
already started the assessments they're
well coated recessing at a particular
time in a particular place and we know
the subject we're assessing on that sort
of big big assumption that is broken
almost all the time but we're taking it
as fixed for here so this is born the
standardized tests and these are sort of
the things that you're sort of used to
seeing this is kind of the epitome of
what is you know you're you're very
controlled in all these things it's a
particular time you know at the end of
11th grade it's at a particular place in
a room in your high school it's that you
know it's you know these things are very
controlled these questions there people
spend years figuring out whether or not
these questions are good so this is
boring the standardized tests and so
this is sort of the far end of like when
you when I say these things are fixed
for this talk I'm really talking about
that's the only environment we have
which approximates these things actually
being fixed once again at Newton that's
not the case we have we're using we're
seeing people in their courses actually
using these things and so a lot of these
things aren't fixed so you have to deal
with this noise but just to keep a
picture in your head for this talk it's
going to be talking about these sorts of
environments and these sorts of tests so
all these sort of control tests have a
lot of sort of types of assessments you
can imagine I'm just going to keep
simplifying here one only one so all
these sort of have a good sort of notion
of correct or incorrect except for one
of them which is free response and as we
all know free response questions are
great for very broad overviews of what
students know but they make it very hard
to grade in a consistent manner and so
you know if you've ever sort of SAT
through high school you probably got
your teacher Lee Hannity of these
rubrics that said you know if you do in
the category of grammar you can get a
three if you do these things and that's
really an attempt to sort of build in a
standard as standardized grading for
these types of assessments that's very
hard to get right and so hence we end up
in the standardized assessment world so
today we're going to be talking about
mostly about again just to sort of set
things you sort of fill in the blank and
multiple choice type questions where
correct and incorrect is actually easy
so that's for today once again there's a
whole broad class of these things but
just to sort of talk about what models
we're going to chat
about today sort of setting setting the
tone and so boiling it down to the sort
of what were what we're trying to do
today is we're going to try to measure
some sort of latent proficiency
parameters some sort of ability some
sort of skill that students have we're
going to do it through binary tasks so
they get to answer a question we get to
declare them correct or incorrect and so
this is that's all we're going to get to
do and this is the very traditional
setting of psychometric so you're
talking your your ets your s80 you're a
CT all those sorts of things like the
very traditional setting and but there's
sort of one thing that we will have some
control over is that tasks are different
is that we can distinguish between tasks
tasks and have properties son might be
more difficult so it might be more
discriminating and so that's going to be
one thing that we are going to have some
control over and moreover this sort of
there's a colon a sub title of this talk
which is like a sort of theirs whatever
it is other settings and so this this
sort of notion of sort of measuring a
latent parameter through binary task is
not at all unique to education and so
just to sort of give you you know where
these sort of model classes come from
we've been talking so far about these
standardized exams where your binary
thing is right or wrong but there's a
lot of other things you can do so you
can talk about you know if you ask a
computer is this the number three you
know that's that's also sort of one of
these classes where there's you know a
right or wrong answer this is either a
number three or it's not and you can ask
the computer yes or no they things like
football games there you know all these
sort of head-to-head competitions you
can do where you have you know you're
trying to order teams you're trying to
rank them and you're trying to say well
you know I get a binary look into I
can't just sort of sit at them and say
like your talent is thus right I only
get to assess them through binary
assessments whether by playing other
teams and whether whether or not they
win or lose right and similarly there
are things like triplet questions inside
of crowdsourcing where you can see
things like so this is like a far end of
things where you can say things like you
know which of these things on the right
is more similar to the thing on the left
and out of curiosity because this is a
fun slide who says be good okay
okay I say I say be too but so the rest
of you I assume say see ya it's a
rainbow hair in the in the ears and the
horn it's just like you know the sea has
a sea as a boring it's like obviously
that's less similar but anyway so these
are so in this case the sort of binary
thing is greater or lesser and so there
so there's all these sort of ways where
we can sort of start to ask about like
the skills of various things the skills
of football teams the skills of crowd
Sorcerer's the skills of students and
always through these sort of binary
questions and so the rest of the
stockmen gave a quick tour of some of
these objective functions that we might
use in order to do this and so hopefully
this is kind of interesting for you all
and just sort of set the scene once more
I like to think of a lot of these things
in sort of terms of three categories so
and it's mostly in terms of what
questions you can ask so these are my
sort of three categories I'd like to
think of so are your questions do your
questions have deterministic or
probabilistic responses so what do I
mean by that if I ask a question between
like the numbers one and two which one
is bigger that is a deterministic
response right to is always going to be
bigger and unless like your computer
gets bombarded by the wrong neutrino
it's always going to say 2 is greater so
whereas on the other hand of
probabilistic response might be
something like it's raining outside when
Michigan and Ohio State are playing and
so Michigan just happens so happens to
lose right you know that's that's a
weird thing that should never happen but
the rain just sort of brought it on and
so these are so those are sort of like
probabilistic things like you don't
necessarily know what the outcome is
going to be ahead of time in the student
setting this is something like imagine a
multiple-choice exam where if you have
five responses to a question that are
possible and you know you don't know
anything well you have a twenty percent
chance of getting right just through
guessing that's very probabilistic but
there's a there's a worse fit to that
which said suppose you know enough that
you can eliminate two of them well now
your chance is thirty-three percent and
so it's like the the the probabilistic
is sort of multi-leveled here so we're
going to integrate all that out it turns
out and so don't worry about it but
that's the notion between deterministic
probabilistic there's also these
comparisons between head-to-head to
intermediaries so head to heads are
these things like comparing one and two
directly to each other is this one
greater than this one
it's things like it's things like
baseball teams playing each other you
get to like your ranking baseball teams
and you're throwing them against each
other and to ask which question which is
bigger you're directly asking which is
bigger whereas an intermediary might be
something like you ask these sort of
common questions between them this is
the exam setting where you say like
please answer these ten questions and
depending upon you how you answer them
versus how you know how you know Sam
answers them versus how Julie answers
them will say which one of you is better
at this topic right so that's sort of
wanted for you so that intermediary is
sort of another sort of dimension and a
final dimension is whether you know the
answer you don't ahead of time and so if
so when I give somebody a multiple
choice question I presumably know that
the answer is B that's very useful to me
because I can actually then assess
whether or not the answer is correct but
there are things like those triplet
questions where I don't actually know
which one of your C is more similar to a
right and I want if I want to find out
through crowd sourcing say which of
these things more similar so that's
actually a very hard case we're not
going to spend too much time on it but
as sort of a matrix you can sort of
think of these things in sort of this
way there are deterministic head-to-head
and known answers or basically sorting
you know you have a list of a bunch of
numbers and you want to sort them we
have great ways to do this I assume you
all know merge sort or something please
close enough to it if you go by
intermediaries get to things like 20
questions you know I get to ask you
questions you know is it bigger than a
bread box and you answer them but in
this sort of left hand category it's
more about it always in the
deterministic thing it's sort of about
minimizing the number of questions I
have to ask where's in the right-hand
category it's much more about knowing
how much confidence I have in any given
answer before I could even ask how many
questions we need to ask so we're going
to focus on sort of that top right-hand
corner where the responses are known
ahead of time or the answers are known
ahead of time but the responses are
probabilistic and we're going to sort of
divide you into ranking and proficiency
so so let's start with the first one so
it is it is nearly time for the the
great game and so this is the so this is
a case of the head-to-head competition
non-deterministic with known responses
known here is just that once the answer
is once the answer is given in this once
the answer is revealed you know it's
correct
right there's no way the game is won or
it's not just what it is so so who wins
in this case so is there okay who is
anybody not is it Arden opening Michigan
or Ohio State people got well the answer
is obvious so the in this case is a
little hard to sort of go what we're
doing but anyway but if you if you take
you know everybody if you take all of
2013 if you take all of the FBS from
2013 and you sort of plot all these
people so here winners are pointing at
losers and I've sort of clustered them
by you can start yes oh the football
bowl Oh God there thank you yeah it's
the it's the Division one basically they
divided division 1 between division 1a
and division 1b basically and they call
them FBS and FCS as of a few years ago
it's just yeah football yeah so these
are these are the these are the top
college football teams in the country
and the but you can see they can see
their conferences so I've sort of
divided them by conferences so the ones
who are in the same conference or close
together they have little gray boxes
around them and you got all these sort
of like wonky arrows off to the side
these are those FCS teams those sort of
next tier down teams which may be only
play one game against the big boys every
year and so that's what all those other
areas are but you see in the sort of
middle here you see a bunch of these
clusters and you notice them like really
horrible facts about this data set one
is that it's very dense in these
conferences because that's how they work
but also it's very sparse as you sort of
go between things and so we can ask so
suppose that we have a graph like this
these are the questions we've asked
we've had all these people play games we
can't have anymore the season's over and
they're going to get concussions if you
have them play too much so so we can ask
so what sort of objective function might
want to this so crowd participation what
sort of objective function would you
want to sort of rank the teams if all
you have is this graph so what's a
anybody have a good good idea sorry what
win-loss ratio that's a good one that's
a good one it's not the one that's I'm
going to go for that second as opposed
to first so what's sorry spilling court
I don't even know that one interesting
okay I don't know it
ok I think that's basically what I'm
going for ok so we'll just sort it so
here I'll give you I'll give you the
objective function i'm going for which
is to minimize the number of out of
order teams so the idea is that so
suppose you had a situation like this so
michigan obviously beats ohio state but
then ohio state beats notre dame and the
notre dame beats michigan so we would
expect in this sort of situation is that
michigan must be great bigger than ohio
state ohio state must be better than
Notre Dame and Notre Dame must be better
than Michigan but we can't have that so
we have to put one person out of order
but the problem is that like you know
who's number one right and the problem
is that if you just know this then I can
choose any one of them to be number one
and my objective function is still
equally minimized so this is the problem
is there's sort of this big ambiguity
here there's no room to sort of bring in
your domain knowledge that Michigan is
obviously number one and so the so
there's no room for priors it's just
completely ambiguity and big you ascend
a lot of these things and it also has
this other problem which is that another
name versus objective function is the
minimum feedback arc set problem and
this turns out to be a px hard so if you
are not familiar with the class apx
problems just be sad it's basically NP
hard but for approximation as opposed to
actually determining the answer so this
is this is this is very sad but in case
you want to use it there are some
approximations available to you in
Python so the I graph package has this
lovely approximating algorithm called
EADS algorithm never run the exact
solution I tried to get it for you all
but I let it run for five hours and it
wasn't nearly done so i gave up but eads
algorithm is very good and there are
some extensions to it for instance my
co-workers ruben knife and Zach Nichols
had this paper coming out in its
workshop in 2014 and a few weeks about
improving it in the context of education
there are some objective functions
they're sort of so the maximal goodness
that properties that you can get out of
it but so now we're going to go back to
the win-loss ratio so this is so I'm
going to do a fancy version of the
win-loss ratio and this is going to be
the sort of first track into sort of
what we do at newton frequently so the
idea is sort of defined this latent
awesomeness parameter which will call
fate of T 1 beta / team
and this is going to determine the
probability of winning in a head-to-head
matchup that's a sort of theme and now
we have a problem we can just maximize
the likelihood because we can determine
this probability and we can just go
maximize the function so in general
principle is that these combinatorial
problems like number of edges i removed
is a hard thing if you can turn it into
I've got a real number and I want to
maximize some function it's a lot easier
still still frequently hard but it's
like a lot easier so here we're going to
do is this awesomeness parameter is
going to be the thing we're going to
rank on it's going to be some random
real number that we don't have too much
control over but the point is that we've
sort of turned we've sort of set it up
so this this is the parameter that
controls your probability of winning a
head-to-head matchup that's this notion
of awesomeness that we want and it's a
real number so we can maximize a
function this becomes much easier for
computers to deal with so the
traditional way of doing this is
something called elos method and this is
sort of developed in the 60s for chess
ranking and the idea is that so you see
we just define the probability that a
beats be the team avg beats Team B is
the logistic function of the difference
in their skills so these theta a and
theta B or their skills and logistic of
the difference so if you're not familiar
with it logistic it's the sigmoid curve
and it shows up in logistic regression
which I assume all of you know and if
you think of it this way this is
basically logistic regression where the
the points the things work line to
classify or the games and the features
are the skills but the point is that we
care more about the skills we care more
about the features than we do about the
points which is the opposite of logistic
regression and you think about logistic
regression you really want to classify
points you don't care about the features
per se here you really care about the
features the points are already fixed
for you so that's kind of what we're
doing with this this is the idea and
just to note if theta a is huge then you
get one over one plus zero and so that's
going to be the probabilities we need
one if they date is very small you get
one over one plus infinity which is zero
so that's probably the winnings very
small backwards
you can yeah you can definitely do a
pseudo count kind of thing to correct
for that but we're assuming they only
play each other once and so there's sort
of that like this is the pseudo count in
some sense is the probability is kind of
a pseudo count and so in the traditional
way we take the ark backs over theta of
the wii some of the log-likelihood and
if you do that so i think i'm not going
to have too much time let's see what's
here how I don't have a time what time
is it a much time to have left oh great
okay so I'm probably not gonna have time
to show you too much code but I do have
a bunch I have all the sort of code that
generates this online and their
exercises for you in fact and you may
feel free to submit pull requests which
solve the exercises and I will I promise
that I will get with them within a week
unless somehow this video goes viral and
I get like you know a thousand of them
but if but there are exercises with the
Python through how I did all this online
including ipython notebooks and whatnot
else so if you do this you actually end
up with this list if you do this for
those football games you end up with
this list and so who can tell me sort of
the weird thing about this like the
really there there at least two weird
things about this sure yeah
yep so that's that's very true so you've
got this very sort of big jumpiness in
the scores that's actually a if you
actually look at the distribution
they'll probably look about normal and
that's actually a good thing I didn't
actually do that you should look at them
other things you can notice yeah exactly
so yeah this is this here's your domain
knowledge here so what what the heck are
these people doing up top also
Michigan's on the list that's really the
third things you should know at Ohio
State is sorry it's next week i have to
like really be going for this so the but
you notice there georgia southern North
Dakota State Northern Iowa McNeese State
Towson Fordham there FCS teams like what
are they doing there like they obviously
are not as good as Alabama Auburn
Missouri Louisiana State LSU all these
people I mean obviously if you have the
domain knowledge right and this is the
key that domain knowledge you remember
that graph is very very very sparse and
so when when that happens with these
like low sample sizes and that's varsity
you end up with a lot of things like
this and so what can you do about it
well so there are these extensions that
you can make this very easily the
traditional thing to do is to add priors
so in these regularization terms so for
instance you might have a prior that
says you know Florida should have a very
high starting score and you know Towson
on the other hand should have a very low
starting score this is like a very thing
you might want to do and obviously below
point number three and but and so it
turns out they're sort of some fun
things that this does for you one of
which is that it makes your objective
function convex so if you further
playing along at home this is not a
convex function and this is a means
words to you but it's only convex
because of 11 dimensional thing which is
that you can add a constant to all the
betas simultaneously and you get exactly
the same number so if u theta a plus C
minus theta B plus C is Theta a minus
theta B so it's not coming back because
it doesn't have a unique maximum so it's
not convex but turns out you're adding
these priors will make it convex so for
those of you who know these words that's
a good thing and more ever allows for
you to toss in this domain knowledge to
make it for sparsity and that's really
one of these key things is that when you
have
sparse samples you really have to
include the domain knowledge and sort of
one of your challenge exercises if you
go home and do this is to make Boise
State be number one because the one of
the great criticism the bold
championship series was that boise state
kept going undefeated for years and
years and years and still ended up in 12
place every year and it's because the
the bowl championship series were
putting these massive priors on it
basically say like Boise State surely
can't be greater than 12th place because
their boise state right and so these are
these sort of things where that that was
that that was them imposing prior
knowledge on this ranking and then
saying like okay well this is the order
we're going to get so one of your
challenges basically is that if you put
on different priors you can sort of
force various different rankings on this
and this is one of your great challenges
of the data scientist is being judicious
and how you do that and knowing the
consequences of it so go forth and
explore with priors in this case there's
also one other sort of extension that
you can do and just because I mentioned
ello this is actually what he did the
stochastic version of this model the
stochastic gradient descent version this
model it has a very nice update function
so if you know SGA it's a very very
simple update function and this allows
for all those people who don't want to
recompute the maximum every night so
somebody like Xbox who has millions of
users but doesn't like want to actually
have to go forth and do a big Hadoop job
every night to update the rankings
because they don't want to spend the
money on it they can just do this online
and it's close enough so this is the
other great thing about this particular
thing for this problem and in fact it's
used by I think I think it's still used
by xbox live it's called true skill for
them and yahoo games I think God's
something similar and there's a bunch of
other people okay but warning just to go
over again no you know the sparsity
means that priors hit a strong effect
the top of the heap is little incentive
to play so this is this small sample
size problem basically and really one of
the big things that there's no room for
improvement it's not you're not tracking
people over time and that's sort of a
big problem but so too just to quickly
go over the case that Newton cares about
and I have three minutes I think so in
this case so what happens if you have an
intermediary instead and this is the
exam content
and so this is the case of proficiency
and here the objective function we
defined the same way except that
questions are now essentially different
students so we just there to save we put
a head head contest between students and
questions and questions and students and
it turns out if you do that you get the
exact same objective function just
slightly modify it a bit and you end up
with the probability that student gets a
question queue right as being this
difference here theta is going to be a
student's for efficiency and beta is
going to be a questions difficulty and
you can take an Arg max just like we did
before now it's over Thetas and betas so
it's over the probability this is the
probably they get it right so you take
the sub more questions ago right minus
some of the questions that got wrong and
that's your thing and just to point out
one more time so that you know in case
you haven't seen this before the hear
this if that kink where fifty percent is
is what beta is going to be and so if
you make the question really difficult
it moves to the right and the
probability of a fix that student with a
fixed proficiency getting that right
goes to zero remove it far to the left
so beta in the bottom is negative 2
dolla sudden goes up to a hundred
percent so you can do the same sort of
thing once again codes online ipython
notebooks are online bunches of district
plays and whatnot else unfortunately
this was meant to be i meant to be a
40-minute talk and it's apparently only
30 minutes so the the so there are
features of this particular thing so
students and questions are ranked on the
same scale items can be more or less
difficult and you can tailor an exam to
a particular grade level these are like
a bunch of things that sort of gives you
where you can if you can rank students
if you can and rank questions
simultaneously you can start to target
particular difficulty levels of students
and whatnot but it still has some
problems sort of sort of big ones or
things like distinguishing between
features of questions maybe you know
that that big question getting that
assessment right coding it right which
concept is it assessing is still a very
hard problem so you can imagine it might
assess multiple concepts what does that
mean turns out a simple thing to do is
it just like YouTube just regression add
features just right or wrong this is
obviously not a real use case for a lot
of people you have free responses that
may be kind of right and also learning
over time
still a problem but temporal models of
this or like a long or much longer
discussion email me if you're really
curious about temporal models of student
proficiency because those things are
picky and that's basically and pictures
of performance and I guess I can show
you one picture because I promised some
pictures in the abstract so you can see
so you sort of randomly simulate some
data and you can see this this does in
fact recover the original it is a good
recovery algorithm the very least from
simulated data so I promise you some
pictures here are some pictures use the
seaborne library by the way these things
are awesome and yeah so Pearson hi
Pearson ours in both cases okay I am out
of time so I'll skip all the other
things and just say thank you the code
is here feel free to go forth it's PI
data 2014 at my github its cage Wilson
so if you can do the exercises